je m'ennuie
évidemment puisque je suis seul
aujourd'hui casimiri partie très bonne
heure pour aller jouer enfin les bons
l'axé aminé matin et moi je suis tout
seul dans cette sinistre maison
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
je si je vais téléphoner à tout le monde
je trouverai quelqu'un pour manière
comprise -
voyant
alors
je dis bonjour il n'y en a pas coutume a
reconnu ouais ouais j'ai besoin de voir
tout de suite ouais moi c'est très
urgent merci à lui
et quelques heures et bien sûr des
questions idiotes
bonjour léonard tu n'aurais pas vu
casimir non
mais moi en revanche je suis là et je
m'ennuie eh ben je suis désolé les gars
mais je suis très pressé leurs oeufs etc
se joint
à cette jeunesse
il m'a même pas dit au revoir enfin il 7
juin qu'est ce qu'elle fait
chers amis bonjour monsieur du snop vous
pourriez frappé avant d'entrer
pardonnez moi mon intrusion chers amis
mais ma motivation est profonde avez
vous vu casimir aujourd'hui il joue au
vent les bons amis de ses amis l'a pas à
mille fois merci menacer mais qu'est ce
qu'ils ont tous aujourd'hui
c'est toujours comme ça quand on a
besoin de quelqu'un
micheline est toujours pas j'appelle
l'europe est vraiment
alors le kiosque
moteur personnes allons y signer en à
whisky sa cuisine lire bonjour j'ai
prévu casimir facteurs ah non facteur
non je sais pas où il est moi c'est ça
c'est ça envoie au revoir
mecelec pas en vrai ce n'est pas vrai
ils sont tous devenus fous un jour un
jeu me je suis heureux de voir c'est
vrai mais bien sûr je n'ai pas
l'habitude de mentir
excuse moi mais tu es tellement gentil
je suis tout était mais tu n'es pas mal
à aider de jeunes et je t'en ben rien il
ne te manque pas de moi je t'ai fait
venir parce que je m'ennuie à voilà
l'explication c'est pour ça que c'est
gentil au lieu de faire des
constatations qui émane à rien 1 tu
ferais mieux de me trouver une idée
unités mais bien sûr pan le plus
m'ennuyer kouao mais ne t'énerve pas
comme ça sinon moi je vais partir très
bien je vais essayer de ne pas crier ben
tu as une idée
une idée ben écoute ça n'est pas
difficile tu pourrais faire un jeu avec
les emplois tu veux que je les appelle
géant des jo pourquoi je perds toujours
bon très bien et bien que tu devrais je
sais pas dessiner sculpter une part
comme monsieur du snug site ronan c'est
trop difficile
et puis on se met des tâches partout on
en attrape un tueur partout sur l'île
ouen et je déteste avoir les doigts ça
mais ça n'est pas grave les canaris si
vite te laver les mains avant je suis
pas là pas changé non
tu sais tu n'es vraiment pas commode
voyons est ce que tu sais chanter
gentil mais ça c'est très bien c'est
très agréable ça c'est une idée
formidable unis dix mois qu'est ce que
je pourrais chanter c'est quoi on
pourrait commencer par quelque chose de
sa hâte en ti
lalalalalalalalala j'aime beaucoup les
filles a reconnu parker attendent à
manama
c'est le même c'est pas très juste obama
madame est
génial je te le dis bravo à m tian nord
enfin c'est tout votre bible bello n'a
heureusement fait c'est pas si
c'était un jury et un
joli
c'est fini léonard
julie
[Musique]